[Music]
keeping a diary is a childish habit but
this childish habit may now be
worthwhile even to a serious man
it is clear we are now entering the
storm
of revolution
at a meeting yesterday of deputies
politicians scholars and writers even
the most conservative man talked about
the coming revolutions as certainty
counts and barons landlords and
businessmen all applauded skating
criticisms of the government and
acclaimed the approaching revolution
these men weary feminized accustomed to
lives of comfort calling for revolution
presented a curious spectacle
like heedless children they manifested a
curiosity into joy in meeting such an
interesting development
i had a vision of the french ruling
classes before the 18th century
revolution like these russians their
emasculated aristocracy too greeted the
storm with laughter not reflecting that
it might rob them of their property and
even of their lives
do you think that the guillotine will be
necessary for us also in the near future
asked one of my students in the workers
university of petrograd i do not know i
replied but i am certain that if you
contemplate the guillotine for your
enemies the same guillotine will cut off
your head a little later the guillotine
always kills first the well-fed but
later on it gets to the poor also
do not forget this it may be useful to
you if revolution really comes
street demonstrations of poor women and
children demanding bread and herrings
eternal voice of all revolutions had
previously led to the looting of one or
two shops but today the demonstration
became larger and noisier the rioters
today stopped tram cars turning over
some of them plundering a good many
shops and even attacking policemen many
workmen have joined the women and a
general strike and great excitement
resulted after the wrecking of the trams
something more important may next be
overthrown
the tsar's throne for instance
things are drifting that way
if future historians look for the group
that began the russian revolution let
him not create any involved theory
the russian revolution was begun by
hungry women and children demanding
bread and herrings
only later did they together with
workmen and politicians become ambitious
to wreck that mighty edifice the russian
autocracy
it goes steadily on
yesterday three men and one woman were
killed
today more
the orderly routine of life is broken
shops and offices are closed in the
university instead of lectures political
meetings are held
newspapers appear irregularly
revolution has pushed one foot over the
threshold of my country
today
the same crowds on the nevsky prospect
are larger the police are idle and
irresolute one hears that even the
cossacks have refused to disperse the
crowds
this means that the government is
helpless and their machine broken
rioters have begun to kill policemen the
pavlovsky regiment is in revolt we are
told that the minister of the interior
is recruiting special squads of police
and is equipping them with machine guns
to be placed on rooftops for merciless
suppression of demonstrations
this half-mad paralytic can do nothing
much however
the end is very near
or
it is only the beginning
this video has been kindly supported by
surf shark just like privacy and freedom
of speech was constrained in the ussr
there are more and more places in the
world today where the internet is being
restricted where your privacy is being
threatened companies are always
hoovering up your data and linking it to
your ip address
surfshark vpn keeps your identity safe
by encrypting all the information sent
between your device and the internet and
masking your ip address
they also have a bonus feature that will
give you truly organic search results
and avoid personal ads meaning you can
take control of what you really want to
be searching for
something i find indispensable living in
spain is that you can use surfshark to
change your virtual location when you
want to watch international versions of
netflix hbo or anything they have more
than 3 200 servers in 95 countries
follow the link below and use my code
voices of past for an exclusive 83 off
plus three months for free with the 30
days money back guarantee you can also
get their antivirus service for free
throughout june definitely worth giving
a try thanks to surfshark for supporting
history content on youtube
it has come at last at two o'clock in
the morning just now returned from the
duma i hasten to set down the stirring
events of the day at noon telephone
service was discontinued and undisturbed
i resumed my studies until about three
o'clock when one of my students rushed
in with the news the two regiments armed
and carrying red flags had left their
barrack and were marching on the doomer
there to unite with the workman is this
true i exclaimed incredulously i saw
them myself he replied
hastily leaving the house we hurried to
the troisky bridge here we found a large
but orderly crowd listening to the
firing and greedily drinking in every
bit of news nobody knew anything
positive
cavalry police kept the crowds in check
and allowed nobody to cross the neva
boom
who's firing on whom
let's go to the central part of town i
suggested we may learn something there
pharaohs your end is coming how the mob
from where we stood we could see the red
glow of fire near the nikolevsky station
at last at last quite a man pointing to
the ominous reflection
what's burning i asked
the police station he exalted
but there is a fire station in the same
building
that won't help we're going to destroy
all government offices burn smash kill
all police all tyrants all despots he
cried in frenzy
revolutionists are prepared to defend
their duma said my friend kuzmin with
approval
on the contrary i replied a crazy mob is
forcing the doomer into a revolution
which it does not want
you will soon behold the real object of
this demonstration
comrade sorakin at last revolution at
last the day of glory has arrived cried
one of the workers my student others
with him approached me joyfully in their
faces was the light of hope and
exaltation
what are you doing here boys i asked we
were told here to come and help organize
the soviet of workmen as in the
revolution of 1905
why is a soviet necessary i asked
to defend the revolution and the
interests of the workers to control the
government and to proclaim our
dictatorship they replied you'll join us
won't you i haven't been elected thank
you i returned dryly
neither have we been elected but that
doesn't matter in such times such
formalities are needless
i don't agree with you i said and i
added it may be for the defense of the
revolution a workman's committee will
have to be formed but be careful about
any dictatorship
[Music]
food was being brought in a buffet was
set up and girl students began to feed
the soldiers
this produced a sudden lull but outside
i learned things were going badly fires
continued to break out the people were
growing hysterical with excitement and
as for the police they had retreated
again i saw the courtyard of the palace
the fever of liberty had by this time
fairly intoxicated the multitude wild
speeches and shrieks of applause filled
the air
excited in spite of myself i too
listened and deplored it and it was
midnight before i could tear myself from
the place
as no trams or cabs were to be had i
walked a long distance from the doomer
it was very dark and no street lamps
burnt
incessant firing reached my ears and
sometimes the firing seemed so near that
all pedestrians stopped looking around
for shelter
groups of citizens huddled against the
walls of houses to avoid flying bullets
they blazed a very fierce fire the
magnificent building of the high court
being in flames
who started that fire someone exclaimed
is it not necessary to have a court
building for new russia
the question went unanswered
we could see that the other government
buildings were also burning among them
police stations and that no efforts were
being made to extinguish the fires on
the faces of many spectators of this
destruction were expressions of intense
satisfaction
their countenances in the red blaze
looked demonic as they shouted laughed
and danced
[Music]
here and there were heaped wooden
carvings of the russian double eagle and
these emblems of empire torn from shops
and from government buildings were being
thrown on the fires to the cheers of the
crowd
the old regime was disappearing in ashes
and no one regretted it
no one cared even when the fires spread
to private houses
let them go one man said defiantly when
wood is chopped
chips
fly
at two o'clock i reached home and sat
down to write these hurried notes am i
glad or am i sorry i can hardly tell but
certainly in my mind the persistent
apprehensions tonight only a part of the
city is in the hands of revolutionists
but what will happen tomorrow
how long will this disorder continue how
many lives will be taken will these
events weaken or perhaps even destroy
the army is it possible that this may
result in the invasion of russia by the
germans
it seems a terribly dangerous time to
launch a revolution but perhaps my
premonitions are foolish so many
rejoicing and patriotic people cannot be
wrong
who was it that said individuals may be
mistaken for the whole nation never
very well long live the revolution the
autocracy had to be destroyed sometime
therefore away with my doubts and
premonitions i looked at my books and
manuscripts i suppose they will have to
be put aside for a time i reflected this
is no time for study
action is the thing
goodbye beloved friends
[Music]
today the hall of the duma presented
quite a different picture from yesterday
soldiers workmen students citizens men
and women young and old crowded the
place
order cleanliness and restraint were
conspicuous by their absence
his majesty the people were master of
the scene in every room and corner were
meetings and much loud oratory down with
the tsar death to all enemies of the
people long life to revolution and the
democratic republic
one grew tired of their endless
repetition
with a group of my workman students i
entered the soviet room
instead of the original 12 there were
now present three or four hundred men
it seems that anyone who aspires to can
become a member of the body a very
informal election indeed
in the overcrowded room full of tobacco
smoke wild harangues were being
delivered more than one at a time
on the way to the room where the
executive committee of the duma was
sitting i met one of the members mr
ephremoth and learned from him that the
struggle between the committee and the
soviet had begun in earnest and that a
dual power was now contending for
control of the revolution mr ephraimov
greatly agitated feared that the efforts
of the duma to reach an agreement with
the soviet were hopeless he foresaw the
substitution of responsible government
by the mob
but what can we do he asked despairingly
who is acting in the name of the soviet
is it not possible to order soldiers to
arrest these men and disperse the soviet
i asked
such aggression and conflict cannot take
place in the first days of the
revolution was the reply then get ready
for your own dismissal very soon i
warned him
were i a member of your committee i
would act immediately
the duma is still the highest authority
in russia
in the midst of our conversation an
officer burst into the room demanding to
be conducted to the committee of the
duma
what has happened we asked
all the officers of the baltic fleet are
being murdered by soldiers and sailors
he cried his face pallid with excitement
the committee must interfere
my heart turned to ice
it was madness to expect a revolution
without some bloodshed yet as the
officer hurried on to the committee
which would doubtless do it best to save
the human life
what would its best amount to
i learned that markets were being
plundered wholesale by the people
very late at night i reached home
no joy was in my soul
yet i paid myself hope
tomorrow things might be better
tomorrow things
were not better
in the streets the same unruly crowds
the same motor cars with men firing
wildly the same man-hunt of policemen
and counter-revolutionaries
in the duma we received definitive news
that the tsar was to abdicate
the old regime had undoubtedly perished
in both petrograd and moscow the
population is as joyful as at easter
everyone acclaims the new regime and the
republic liberty holy liberty is
everywhere shouted and sung wonderful
revolution revolution without blood pure
as the robes of sinless angels
i've heard this last from crowds of
students parading the streets
it is all quite true of course
bloodshed has not been very terrible
if there are no further victims of the
fanatics our revolution may yet go down
in history as the bloodless revolution
long live the bloodless revolution
[Music]
the political immigrants continue to
return in a few days are expected the
bolshevist leaders lenin trotsky
genevieve and others they are returning
through germany with the assistance of
the german government which has loaned
them a special wagon some of our people
are indignant with the provisional
government which permitted these persons
to return
the rumor is spreading that lenin and
his companions about 40 men were hired
by the german staff to incite civil war
in russia and still further to
demoralize the russian army
i know not if this is true but if it is
what can the government do to prevent it
by the inflamed masses any attempt on
the government's part would be regarded
as counter-revolution
lenin and his companions have arrived
their first speeches at the bolshevist
conference embarrassed even members of
the extreme left
lenin and his group are now very rich
men and as a consequence the number of
bolshevist newspapers pamphlets
proclamations etc have greatly increased
trotsky has taken a very expensive
apartment where did all this money come
from that is the question
socialization has begun the bolshevik
have forcibly taken possession of the
villa of the darts of kashinsky the
anarchists have seized the villa of
derauvo and other houses the owners
being summarily expelled
although they have appealed to the
courts and to the government nothing has
been done to restore their property side
by side with bolshevist speakers stand
others defending the policies of the
government
violent speeches are often followed by
fights about noon today came a rumor
that two regiments fully armed had left
their barrack to support the rioters
firing began sacking of shops by
criminals became general the situation
resembled the first days of the revolt
but in those days citizens were able to
control the masses
late last night the rioters were
momentarily dispersed but they had
already achieved their purpose
the government has announced that
miliakoff is to be dismissed this means
the government
has fallen for this first concession to
the mob and to the bolshevik is the
beginning of the end of the provisional
government
we we are all living on the edge of a
volcano and at any moment an eruption
may burst forth
not a pleasant situation but step by
step we managed to adapt ourselves to it
at any rate it is all interesting enough
[Music]
the abyss has opened at last
bolshevism has conquered
it was all very simple the provisional
government and the first all-russian
soviet were overthrown as easily as was
the tsarist regime
through their military committees of
revolution the bolshevik got control of
the regiments
through the petrograd workers soviets
they became masters of the working
classes
these soldiers and petrograd workmen
commandeered all automobiles in the
street occupied the winter palace the
fortress the railway stations the
telephones and the post
to destroy the old government and to
establish the new required only 24 hours
lying ill all day on my bed i listened
to the steady booming of the cannon and
the spatter of machine guns and crack of
rifles over the telephone i learnt that
the bolshevik had brought up the warship
aurora and it opened fire on the winter
palace demanding the surrenders of
members of the provisional government
still barricaded there
at seven in the evening i went to the
municipal duma with many matters before
us the immediate horror that faced us
was the situation at the winter palace
there a regiment of women and military
cadets were bravely resisting an
overwhelming force of bolshevist troops
and over the telephone minister
konovalov was appealing for aid
poor women poor lads their situation was
desperate for we knew that the wild
sailors after taking the palace would
probably tear them to pieces what could
we do after breathless council it was
decided that all of us the soviets
municipalities committees of socialist
parties members of the council of the
republic should go in procession to the
winter palace and do our utmost to
rescue the ministers the women's
soldiers and the cadets
but even as we prepared to go over the
telephone came the despairing shout
the gates of the palace have been forced
the massacre has begun
hurry the mob has reached the first
floor
all is over
goodbye they break in they are
that last word of kanovalov from the
winter palace
was a broken cry
karensky is defeated the bolsheviks have
taken the banks state and private and my
former friend piatekov has been made
commissary of finance
from the front comes new tales of horror
general issimo de konin has been
murdered with hundreds of other officers
our army is now a wild flying mob which
destroys everything that stands in its
path
german invasion is inevitable
today again i narrowly escape to rest as
i entered the courtyard of our building
a band of prosecutors followed me some
going to the office others remaining at
the gate
fortunately they did not know me by
sight and as it was dark i lingered
outside devising plans of escape one of
our printers emerged from the doorway i
called him and explained my plight
just a moment he said and in a few
minutes he came back with a certificate
identifying me as of the working force
at the gate we were stopped and our
certificates demanded
we showed them and the guard said
gruffly pass on
so again the mouse escaped
it is an interesting fact that this
persecution is conducted by the very men
who a few days ago were loudest in
clamoring for a free press
our daily menu at home becomes exotic
there is no bread but yesterday we
founded a small shop a few tins of
preserved peaches
for bread we prepare cake from potato
skins and find it not too awful to
swallow
long life to the revolution which
stimulates invention and makes the
people more modest in their appetites
and desires
[Music]
this is the last day of 1917
i look back on the year with feelings of
bitterness and disillusionment the year
1917 gave us the revolution
but what his revolution brought to my
country would ruin and disgrace has it
brought us freedom has it bettered the
condition of the people
no
the face of revolution unveiled is the
face of a beast
of a vicious and wicked prostitute not
that of the pure goddess which has been
painted by historians of other
revolutions
i could pray that these historians
themselves might live through a real
revolution we do not know who will save
our russia but whatever sorrows lie
before you now dear country you shall
not perish
from these ashes you shall rise a great
country and a great nation a power among
the powers of the earth
the prospects for 1918
very dark
but come what may i believe in my
country and its historical mission
sooner or later we shall find the way
out
be blessed
every day and night my beloved country
so
you